i've been in recovery for like five
years i guess and i've struggled
recently in the past year during the
pandemic
um but i'm still a strong believer in
recovery and in the 12 steps of recovery
um why do you feel like the 12 steps of
recovery are the 12 steps work
well for so many people and um
do you think that that's the best
modality to uh to obtain
sobriety for um for for addicts
well it isn't obvious that there's a
good alternative
so that's the first thing if aaa
doesn't work it isn't like there's a
preferable treatment
most people cease alcohol use
on their own without medical
intervention we don't know why although
religious transformation seems to be one
and of course the 12 steps
capitalizes on that i think that it's
quite an
intelligent program psychologically
speaking
you know first of all you have to make a
moral inventory
you have to figure out what's wrong in
your life
which would obviously include the
alcohol misuse
you have to rectify that take
responsibility for it try to try to
chart out a new course
you're also provided with a social
structure which is really useful when
you're
trying to stop drinking because it's all
very probable that most of your friends
are going to be
drinkers and so that leaves not only do
you stop drinking but you stop
associating with your friends or maybe
even with your family members
that's really hard yeah so you know an
aaa
doesn't seem to be an exploitative
organization
it's all volunteers um
as and speaking strictly clinically
there it isn't obvious that there's a
better alternative if you were being
strictly scientific
you'd say well there's never been
controlled trials of aa where you
randomly assign people to the aaa group
and to the non-aa group or another
treatment to see head to head which
works better
and there's the problem that many people
drop out
and so you can't tell exactly what the
success rate is but
but that's a in some sense a technical
argument
um it also isn't clear to me that aa
does people harm
right right which is also really
important because
many medical treatments can produce harm
and so the worst you could say is well
maybe it won't work
um so yeah and that's not that big of a
risk
especially right comparatively speaking
yes
yeah if you're already all sick or
something you know even or so
what do you think what do you think it
was that enabled you to stop
drinking like why did you manage it what
did you use
as an alternative well i noticed when i
went well my problem was cocaine
but i worried that if i drank i would do
cocaine i never had a
problem drinking but i was worried that
one could lead to the other
yes undoubtedly i think well
one thing it gave me a place where i
realized that
other people were sharing their thoughts
and feelings and i'd never been in that
kind of environment before
and so to so that was one of the big
things was the emotional sobriety
um and then it helped me having a
relationship with a higher power which
i'd never really had
i right and what difference did that
make do you think
man that made it was the first time in
my life i i
i i felt like something cared about me
unconditionally
and you experienced that oh and i
experienced at a level that shook me man
like i've got electrocuted like it was
yeah that a god just that this inv that
some invisible
thing cared about me at a level that i
could never even imagine
and that no matter if i was good or bad
or if i
did something naughty or nice or
cinnamon or spice
man that this thing loved me and that
was uh
i just never felt that before so for
there to be a way to get to that feeling
that's what made
recovery feel like important to me i
think
yeah well to have an experience like
that is a real gift yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one